it's almost time to start celebrating
the Fourth of July and of course that
always means fireworks especially in
this town every fourth of July injuries
from fireworks are rising up 25 percent
over the past 15 years it is now a
report reporter that is Brian will shows
us just how dangerous they can be
fireworks can be fun and spectacular but
they can also result in serious injuries
this is just one of the many examples of
using fireworks incorrectly it leads to
nearly 9 000 hospital visits every year
and for First Responders the extra work
starts before the fourth our fire Crews
for the couple nights before 4th of July
they really don't sleep and they work
48-hour shifts most injuries come from
illegal fireworks and require extensive
Medical Care the only legal fireworks
are those labeled safe and sane illegal
ones will come off of the ground or fly
or they will explode like an m-80 cherry
bombs firecrackers bottle rockets the
ones you can use look like these people
don't realize is fireworks are
explosives you're playing with gunpowder
and so that's why you have to be 16 in
order to legally purchase safe and sane
and always make sure to have water
nearby but their best advice is to leave
the fireworks to the professionals if
we're being called at me means that a
fire has happened and that somebody's
home has been destroyed